Okay,
let's get started.
Um,
when I was at school
that we were often told,
um,
that one of the great things about
British history was that the country had
never been successfully invaded by a
foreign power since 10 66 when William the
conqueror and the Normans
conquered the Saxon Kingdom.
And this was part of the
national story as we got it.
It was a great deal of emphasis upon
successfully resisting foreign powers,
Spanish armada,
Napoleon,
Hitler,
whatever.
Um,
so no,
no successful foreign invasion since
10 66 and this makes a good story,
but unfortunately it's not actually true.
Uh,
Britain was very successfully
invaded in November,
1688 by a largely Dutch army under
William of Orange Stat holder of the
Netherlands.
But that of course didn't count.
The whole events of 1688 had been
successfully repackaged as the essential
prelude to the English revolution part
to the glorious revolution of 1688 taken
in the classic Whig interpretation
of national history as a fundamental
watershed.
Before 1688,
the country had been beset with chronic
political instability and indeed social
conflict.
60 and 88 cleared the way.
It cleared the way for the establishment
of a stable constitutional monarchy,
cleared the way for political liberty.
It cleared the way for religious
toleration and cultural pluralism,
a triumph of weak principles in that
respect and security of property and
growing economic opulence
and the formation of the
United Kingdom by the Union
of England and Scotland.
And finally the successful assertion of
national power internationally and the
growth of an overseas empire.
Well,
these are some of the key elements
classically stressed from the 18th century
onwards in wig historiography.
It's a bit of a myth,
a particular rather self
serving interpretation of
the national passed with the
strong ideological message
about what it is to be British,
but like all historic
graphical myths of that kind,
it did have a kernel of truth,
even if it airbrushed out an awful lot
of the real complexities of the story and
tended to represent as
being almost inevitable,
a set of outcomes,
which were in fact far more complex,
far more hesitant,
far more messy than
was usually recognized,
but still be that as it may.
These are the processes that we need
to consider in the final days of this
course.
Well,
as you remember,
by 60 and 88 king James the second had
succeeded in undermining the initial
strength of his position when he came to
the crown by utterly alienating what's
usually referred to as the Tori Anglican
majority in the political political
nation.
People upon whom Charles a second had
counted when he faced down the wig
opposition in the exclusion
crisis of 1678 to 81
and at the same time as
he alienated those people,
James had failed to win the trust and
support of the Protestant dissenters,
the low church Anglicans who had been
the backbone of the wig and exclusionist
caused
the extent of this general
alienation from the king.
And his policies was of course revealed
in the fact that some of the leaders of
the political nation,
we're willing to actively
support intervention by a
foreign power in 1688 indeed
to invite it in that
famous letter to William,
the third and even more including James,
the second zone army were willing at
least to acquiesce in the face of Williams
intervention.
They sat on their hands
to this extent.
One could say that the revolution
of 1688 was in different ways,
both a wig and a Tori revolution.
It was in part an elite coup d'etat.
It was impart a country revolution.
It merged a range of political opinion
in opposition to James in opposition to
the specter of popery and arbitrary power
and the political
settlement as it emerged,
reflected that composite
character of the revolution.
On the 22nd of January,
he's 60 and 89 a convention parliament
met to begin working out the settlement.
It had its estimated 319 members of
broadly wig sympathy and 232 abroadly
broadly,
Tori sympathy plus the House of Lords,
but the debates as they went on seem to
have become largely dominated by those
of the middle ground who managed to
hold the minorities of extremists,
both political persuasions in check.
It seems to have been one of those rabbit
instructive situations in history when
the center is tough and holds from
the conventions,
formal definition of the
situation reflected that it
resolved and I'm quoting,
it resolved almost unanimously that King
James the second having attempted to
subvert the constitution of the kingdom
by breaking the contract between king
and people and by the advice of Jesuits
and other wicked persons having violated
the fundamental laws and having
withdrawn himself out of this kingdom has
abdicated the government and that
the throne is thereby vacant.
That's what they resolved and
no carefully and those words,
it's another masterpiece of ambiguity
comparable to the communion service in the
Anglican prayer book of
1559 which you'll remember,
they say that James broke the
contract between king and people.
That's Whig ideology,
the notion of a contract,
but he also withdrew
himself and abdicated,
so he hadn't actually been
deposed for his offenses.
That's an appeal to Tory sympathy.
They didn't believe in resistance to a
divinely appointed and anointed king,
so he'd abdicated as for
the Jesuits and so forth.
Well,
everyone could agree on that
and in all of this,
of course the status of the baby Prince
James was conveniently forgotten.
Now this kind of interpret
it your own way attitude.
Also suffused a lot of the rest of the
settlement as it unfolded in 1589 and 50
90 William was not content
to be simply a regent,
but he and Mary shared the crown until
her death in 60 94 he was king in effect,
but he wasn't an elected king.
He held the crown in right of his
wife who was a legitimate Stuart air,
the Protestant daughter of games a
second by his first marriage and it was
agreed that Mary's youngest sister,
Princess Anne,
would be the next air ahead of any
children that William and Mary themselves
might have.
Again,
all very odd.
The convention also drew up a declaration
of rights later passed into law as the
bill of rights.
It was clear on some matters which
found almost universal ascent,
but it was also cautious and
ambiguous in other respects.
The power of the monarch,
for example,
to suspend the laws was
declared to be illegal,
but the dispensing par of the monitor
traditional dispensing par was illegal
only as it have been exercised of late
I II as it had been exercised by James
the second parliaments should be called
frequently and should be freely elected,
but as yet there were no specific
measures to ensure that that would happen.
Roman Catholics were to be
excluded from the crown,
but as yet there was no specific provision
to ensure that that would be the case
and above all,
the status of the whole
document was rather obscure.
It looked rather like a
contract with the new Monnox,
but in fact the offer of the crown to
William and Mary was not made conditional
upon accepting it.
The offer of the crown was actually
made on the 13th of February before the
declaration of Rights had been presented
to William and Mary and they hadn't
formally accepted it before they were
proclaimed monarchs the next day.
So 1689 saw a series of measures intended
to advance the transfer of power to
William and Mary,
and that was rapidly consolidated
with other acts of parliament,
which again reflect the coalition of
interests involved in the revolution.
They passed a mutiny act that laid down
that no standing army would be permitted
in peacetime unless
authorized by parliament.
They voted income to
the crown by taxation,
but the sums which were voted were
well known to be inadequate for even
peacetime administration,
let alone wartime.
And so parliament would always be needed
in order to grant additional necessary
supply.
They pass a toleration act.
Protestant dissenters were allowed to
worship publicly and by the end of 50 90
some 9,000 dissenting meeting
houses had been opened,
but they were still not
accorded full civil rights.
The Church of England remained
the legally established church.
The test acts was still there to exclude
nonmembers of the Church of England
from holding public office,
but Protestant dissenters were allowed
to worship openly and meanwhile,
Roman Catholics,
Unitarians and Jews were
permitted to worship in private.
They were tolerated officially
altogether.
The settlement of 60 88 and nine
constituted a kind of pragmatic compromise
designed obviously enough to appeal
to as many people as possible and to
alienate as few as possible from
the revolutionary settlement.
John Moral has put it,
well,
he calls it a centrist compromise
and a constitutional blur.
And as with Elizabeth and religious
settlement of 1559 it was full of
inconsistencies and it remained to be
seen just how they would work it out in
practice,
how it would be worked out by political
groups who had somewhat different
interpretations of just
what it actually meant,
but worked out.
It was,
and in the course of
the next 25 years or so,
that involved a significant refashioning
of the state as a result and the
emergence by 1714 of a British
state of a shape and structure,
which no one had quite anticipated in 1688
well that British state,
what's shaped partly by
political principles.
It was shaped partly by political and
religious prejudices and partly also by
the constraining force of
immediate circumstances.
And if those circumstances,
that dominant circumstance,
it was war,
the modern British state,
it could be sad,
was forged under the stresses of war.
William of Orange hadn't intervened in
1688 out of his deep personal concern for
England's religion and liberties.
His intervention was part and parcel
of his life's mission of containing the
threatened had Yemeni of
the French monarchy of Louis
the 14th and in particular
the threat it poses to his own country,
the Netherlands and the price
of Williams intervention was war
war.
First of all to defend the revolutionary
settlement against Jacobite risings
Jacobites being supporters of James
Jacobite risings in Scotland in 1689 to 90
then to oust James the second from
Ireland where he'd landed with an army in
1689 to 91 culminating in
the battle of the boy in it,
which James was defeated
and led back to France.
Then war in the Netherlands against Louis
the 14th between 60 and 88 and 1697 to
contain the French who were
James's principled supporters.
And then again after William the thirds
death in 1,702 renewed war between 1702
and 1713 to defeat the renewed
menace of French hegemony,
which included French recognition
of the claims of James.
The second's son James had died
in 1,701 his son and heir James.
The third to those who supported him was
known as the pretender to the crowns of
England and Scotland.
13 years old when his father died.
So then between 1688 and 1713 we have
a whole generation of major wars being
fought on land and sea,
mostly against the French.
Given its commitment until the revolution
the political nation represented in
parliament was willing though very
reluctant to recognize the need for these
wars,
but at the same time parliament was
acutely sensitive to the danger that they
might lead to a buildup of royal power,
which might threaten its own position,
might raise again that
specter of arbitrary power.
Okay.
Out of the interaction of that necessity
to fight the wars and that anxiety
about where they might lead
their eventually emerged.
What was on the one hand,
a far more powerful state apparatus.
It's been described famously by John
Brewer as the fiscal military state,
which emerges at this time
and yet on the other hand,
it was a more powerful state apparatus
which remained very firmly under
parliamentary control
and the key to the whole
process as you'll be aware,
it was finance,
but to understand that we have to step
back first a little bit in time and look
at what's known as the
financial revolution.
Yeah.
Now,
as you know,
by the standards of the day,
England was a relatively rich country
by the late 17th century and getting
richer
earlier in the century.
However,
governments had rarely succeeded in
tapping that wealth effectively for their
own purposes.
The late 17th and early 18th centuries
in the so called financial revolution saw
a transformation of the fiscal capacity
of the state that is its ability to
raise money for its
purposes and consequently a
transformation of its capacity
for effective action.
This was the outcome of developments
which are in the words of one recent
historian of the financial revolution
transformed the willingness rather than
the ability of the English
people to pay high taxes,
lend large sums and above all repos Greg
trust in the financial institutions of
their parliamentary government.
I tend,
we Rosevear,
I'm quoting
parliamentary government and the trust
which it could inspire was perhaps indeed
the key to this whole development
on the Charles.
The second parliaments,
ultimate control of the public
purse was of course not in doubt,
but as you know,
suspicion of the crown's policies could
mean that parliament was unwilling to
grant supply.
Indeed.
In 1672 the situation in royal
finances had become so bad.
The crown became so overstretched as a
debtor that it led to what's known as the
stop of the Exchequer in which Charles
the second postponed repayments of his
debts to private lenders.
Many London bankers
were completely ruined.
As a result,
it was a very severe blow to the car.
The crown's credit and its
ability to raise money.
Well after 60 and 88 that kind
of situation was transformed,
transformed in less than 10 years in the
face of the need to raise money for the
wars fought to defend the
revolutionary settlement.
It's a long and complex story,
but the essence of it all is quite nicely
contained in a statement made by Lord
Macaulay and his history of all this
written back in 1848 McCourty wrote from a
period of immemorial antiquity,
it has been the practice of every
English government took contract debts.
What the revolution introduced was the
practice of honestly paying them back.
Parliament was now fully in control,
not only of grant of supply,
but of its expenditure.
Annual estimates were made of need.
Supply was voted.
The accounts what audited by
parliamentary commissioners.
Revenue was now regarded as the public
revenue rather than the monarchs revenue
and from 60 98 even the ordinary day
to day expenses of the crown were
controlled by an annual grant,
so called civil list.
The money paid for running the day to
day business of the monarchy as still
happens,
parliaments sanctioned a whole series
of devices to raise money for the wall.
In 60 90 at voted a land tax,
a quite heavy tax on landowners which
brought in a reliable annual income.
Loans were raised on the security
of parliamentary taxation.
Longer term borrowing was achieved by
means of the sale of annuities to the
public with the regular payment of
those annuities secured by parliamentary
taxation.
They tried out lotteries as a way of
raising money again with parliaments
sanction in 1694 the Bank
of England was charted.
Lenders were brought to subscribe to a
1.2 million pound loan with the interest
and the eventual repayment of the
capital guaranteed from taxation.
The Bank of England was not a
central bank in modern sense,
but it was a vehicle devised to raise
money for the needs of the state.
There was also the development of a market
in various forms of state securities
is new state securities
which were being issued.
They could be sold on to third parties
and it was at the core of the emergence
of dealings in stocks,
the beginnings of the
London Stock Exchange.
All of this was initiated in a piecemeal
and a rather improvised manner.
Year by year.
They dreamed up something new as a
way of raising the money they needed.
But gradually by the early 18th century,
it had coalesced into a
system and fundamental to the
whole emerging edifice was
an effective tax system,
which made possible the servicing
of a growing public debt.
Initially the land tax quite heavy,
about 20% on landed income
in the richest counties,
and then increasingly
the use of the exercise,
which was indirect taxes collected by
a growing corpus of public officials,
excise men as they were known
and as a system developed,
there was a growth of confidence
in the financial probity.
And reliability of the state and that
growing confidence transformed people's
willingness to lend their
money to the government.
Public revenues increased massively
by 1700 it's been estimated at about 9%
of national income was being taken in
taxation and by the same year about a
third of the revenue raised by the state
was being used to fund the debts.
By 1714 the national debt had
risen to 48 million pounds,
a massive son by the standards of the day,
most of it funded by parliamentary
pledges to pay the interest and eventually
the principal
in 1717 after the end of the
war of the Spanish succession,
a variety of sinking funds were
established to pay off parts of the debt,
but it was generally recognized that
a public debt of some size reliably
serviced in the way I've described
would be a permanent fact of life.
Thereafter.
In short,
what they done in the financial revolution
was to create gradually a stable
system of public credit
based upon parliamentary
taxation and with it a regime
which has been described as
having the political support,
the administrative capacity,
and the fiscal base required to accumulate
and service a perpetual national
debt.
So in the years after 60 98 the fiscal
capacity of the state was rapidly and
massively transformed.
John Brewer calls this a fiscal military
state because so much of the enhanced
public revenue was spent on war.
Military expenditure as a proportion
of national income was about 2% at the
death of charter second in 1685 by 1700
it was 4% in 1710 at the height of the
war of the Spanish succession,
it peaked at over 14% and then it settled
down after piece came in 1714 at about
5% even in peace time,
mostly as a result of
the regular expenditure,
which was maintained maintaining the
Royal Navy as a permanent military
presence.
Now,
all of this could have been potentially
destabilizing and there were times in
the 60 nineties as they went from
year to year trying to raise money,
that the whole thing sometimes teetered
on the edge of potential collapse.
There was a real risk in 60 96 that they
wouldn't be able to raise enough money,
for example,
to pay the army,
but they managed to sustain it.
They improvise their way
through and eventually,
as I said,
it coalesced into a system which provided
the underpinning for the emergence of
England as a significant military par,
a significant world power,
but if parliament was willing to provide
the resources which made possible that
kind of growth in the power of the
state parliament also exacted a price.
It exacted a price politically.
As John Brewer shows the prevalence
suspicion of central government amongst
parliamentarians meant that they
exerted themselves to try to shape this
emergent state operators in ways that
would accord with their own preferences,
their so called country attitudes.
That suspicion of central government,
the need for annual parliamentary
supply meant that parliament became a
permanent part of the
government of the country.
They had to have parliamentary
sessions every single year.
No one had anticipated
that it just happened.
It was necessary.
The money which was granted to the
government by these parliaments was very
carefully monitored according
to the system of appropriation,
the principle of appropriation,
that's to say parliamentary grants could
be used only for the purposes for which
they had been granted.
Therefore,
policy had to be in a accord with
parliaments wishes to meet parliaments,
approve
royal ministers might
be chosen by the crown,
but again,
they needed to be men who could command
a support of a majority in the House of
Commons.
If they had no majority
in the House of Commons,
they weren't able to achieve anything.
They weren't able to get
the supply that they needed
and in other more specific ways,
as brewer puts it,
fiscal control put the bite into
the bark of country politics.
Sometimes they would
tack on to Revenue Bills,
a place act.
That was an act which attempted to exclude
government officials from the House
of Commons in order to preserve the
independence of parliament in 60 94
Williams.
The third was forced to accept a new and
strengthened triennial act under which
parliament should be not only
called every three years,
but should not sit longer than
three years without new elections,
so they had to have
elections every three years,
a very significant curtailment of the
royal prerogative to call and then to
dissolve parliament.
When the king chose William
resisted it strongly,
but he had to give way in the end by 1700
the relationship between the ministers
in the royal government,
those who sat in the cabinet and
parliament had become the crucial axis of
political life and the struggle of those
ministers to establish and to maintain
a working majority in parliament.
Above all in the House of Commons was
giving rise to an increasingly vigorous
brand of organized party
politics in parliament.
The old abusive labels wig and Tori,
which as you know,
had first appeared to hurl against
your enemies in the exclusion crisis.
These were now revived and perpetuated
to describe different groupings,
groupings,
which had different interpretations
of the meaning of the revolution and
differences of view about
how the revolutionary
settlement should be developed
by 1700.
The wigs and the Tories were
fairly organized groups.
They had their own favorite
meeting places in London.
They had their own newspapers,
they had their own national followings.
The adversarial politics of Whigs and
Tories influenced political life at the
level of the city at the
level of county politics.
It erupted periodically in the vigorous
contests of the many general elections,
which were held between 60 and 90 and 17,
15.
There were 10 general elections in those
years in which it's estimated something
like a quarter of the adult male
population exercise their votes and the
election campaigns were full of competing,
uh,
of,
um,
competition for seats in which the Whigs
and Tories organized their supporters.
These alignments were even such that in
the city of York where they had assembly
rooms were polite society met to
hold balls and other occasions,
concerts and so forth.
There was one assembly room for
the wigs and one for the Tories.
But if Whigs and Tories fought furiously
for dominance in both parliament and in
local politics,
there were also vital areas in
which they were fundamentally at one
and that was revealed in 1,701 when the
death of Princess Anne's only child,
the ultimate heir to the throne called
into question the future succession of
the crown.
This precipitated the so called
act of settlement of 1,701
it's known as the act of settlement,
but the actual title of the
act is quite significant.
It was actually called and act for the
further limitation of the crown and
better securing the rights of the subject.
This act which obtain support from
both sides politically passed over 57
possible claimants to the crown on the
grounds that they were Roman Catholics
and it fixed the succession on
the electors safier of Hanover,
ruler of a small north German principality
who was descended from King James.
The first safier of Hanover and her heirs
were chosen as the nearest Protestant
successes.
The act also required that future Monica
should be communicated to the Church of
England.
It forbade their marriage
to Roman Catholics.
It restricted the movements of the Monique
outside the kingdom could not leave
the kingdom without permission.
And in addition,
it made Royal Privy Council is
more accountable to parliament,
restricted the election of place,
men from the government to the House
of Commons and declared that in future
judges in the law courts should enjoy
their tenure during good behavior and not
merely at the will of the Monique.
So a specific contingency.
The problem over the succession gave
rise to a far reaching set of statutory
restrictions on the crown's actions,
which found widespread support
in some.
Then by the time Queen Anne came to the
throne in 1702 with the prospect of the
future,
Hannah Varian succession,
which actually eventually took
place in 1714 when Electra Sufi,
his son George became king.
With all of that,
it can be said that some of the
fundamental political issues which had so
disturbed the 17th century,
we're close to being resolved with
general acceptance of those resolutions.
The issue of the security
of the Protestant religion
and of the toleration of
religious dissenters had been resolved.
The issue of parliament's role and its
permanence in the constitution had been
resolved.
The issue of the royal prerogative in
matters of state and how far it could be
controlled or reduced the problem
of effective government finance.
The problem of how to contain differences
of political principle without those
partners and differences leading to the
breakdown of government or to civil war
had been resolved with party politics.
The structures and practices of the
English state had been refashioned in a
manner which both enhance the power of
the state and at the same time contained
the part of the state in ways which
would be conducive to safe guarding the
liberties of the subject.
Well,
one final element remains
from 1,707 this emergent
state was not just an English,
but a British state with
the constitutional union
in May 1,707 of England and
Scotland,
Ireland remained technically a separate
kingdom until 1,801 the one ruled by a
Protestant landed elite.
Now in Scotland,
much of the kingdom and particularly
lowland Scotland and some parts of the
highlands,
those parts of the Western
highlands of Scotland,
which were dominated by the clan Campbell,
who were both Protestants
and wigs in politics,
much of Scotland then had
welcomed the revolution of 1688
and rebellions by some of the Jacobite
clans of Highland Scotland where swiftly
put down in 60 90
but in the years that followed if the 60
nineties witness to kind of resurgence
of Scotland's political independence,
it was also a propound profoundly
traumatic decade for the Scotts.
Scotland remained a
relatively poor country,
magnificent landscape,
but somewhat barren.
It was largely a subsistence economy in
the rural area areas and it was a very
fragile one.
In 60 95 to 99 Scotland's suffered
dreadful famine known as the Ileus of King
William.
It's possible that as much as 13% of
the population of Scotland died in those
years,
and indeed much more in the most marginal
Highland areas in Highland Aberdeen.
Shia up here,
the,
um,
Highland areas of northeastern Scotland,
it's estimated that perhaps a third of
the population died in the 60 nineties.
Scotland had relatively
little manufacturing industry.
It was little developed.
The most important sector
was the manufacturer of
linen on Tayside up here and
over near Glasgow in the West.
Um,
and this was an industry which
was principally dependent
upon selling that linen
to English markets.
Overseas trade was also
relatively limited.
Uh,
Scotland was excluded from England's
colonial trade as a separate kingdom and
efforts made by some Scott's in the 60
nineties to try to establish a colonial,
um,
foothold of their own when they attempted
to establish a colony in Panama,
the Darien scheme in 1595 to 99.
Unfortunately,
those efforts proved to
be a disastrous failure,
not least because the English government
refused to help a venture which
antagonized Spain by attempting to
establish a Scottish colonial presence in
territories regarded as
part of the Spanish empire.
Well,
all of these unhappy events provided the
political and economic context of the
union of 1,707
the Scots were extremely
conscious of course,
of their distinctive national
identity and history.
They were anxious to preserve
then national integrity.
In the 60 nineties the Scottish parliament
was enjoying a greater independence
from the crown than it had ever done.
So here's a two,
but economically,
the most dynamic sectors
of the Scottish economy,
we're heavily dependent upon England,
and some Scots were also attracted to
the possibility of obtaining greater
access to English markets
and participation as equals
in English colonial trade.
Meanwhile,
the English government was interested in
a closer union with Scotland for quite
different reasons,
for largely political reasons.
In 1,701 when the act of settlement
was past fixing the succession in the
Hanoverian line,
the Scottish parliament did not at first
follow England's lead in recognizing
the Hanoverian succession.
This raised in the early
years of the 18th century,
a potentially dangerous situation.
What if the Scottish parliament decided
to recognize a Stewart succession
decided to vest their
crown in the old line,
the Stewart line after Queen Anne's death.
If that happened,
it could potentially provide
a major security risk.
It could return to a situation in which
the two kingdoms which had been joined
only in the person of their
monarchs might fully separate.
That might pose a new threat
to England from the north,
especially if the Scots had a
steward crown allied to the French.
The English government therefore began
to put on pressure for a union which
would remove that threat and they were
willing to use economic leverage to try
to do so.
In 1,705 the English parliament passed
the alien acts which excluded the Scots
from English markets unless they commenced
negotiations for a possible union.
And on the other hand,
it held out the prospect of economic
advantages for Scotland if they were
willing to do so.
Now in Scotland,
the issue was very passionately debated
both in parliament and in the streets of
Edinburgh,
but in those debates,
the economic advantages of union soon
came well to the fore as one opponent of
the union,
Alexander Fletcher of sole tool and put
it the economic issues where the bait
that covers the hook
and in the event
that carried the day with those of the
Scottish elite in Scotland's parliament
who ended up making the decision in
1,707 after protracted negotiations or
Treaty of union was at last agreed there
would be a single United Kingdom of
Great Britain with a single flag.
The Union Jack,
you'll see lovingly drawn on
the bottom of your handout,
the St George Flag of England,
the Saint Andrew's flag of Scotland,
and how they merged together into the
union jack flag now familiar to us on the
tops of mini cars and
on swimming costumes.
The hanoverian succession to the
United Throne was recognized.
The Scots would join a single parliament
for the United Kingdom meeting in
Westminster.
16 members would be sent to the House
of Lords 45 to the House of Commons.
In rough proportion to population.
The Scottish legal system,
however,
would retain its full
jurisdictional independence.
The Scottish church,
the cook would also retain its
independence as a Presbyterian church,
but 15 of the 25 articles of the
Treaty of union concerned economic
arrangements,
the Scots would be granted
full access to English trade,
lower taxes would be levied in Scotland
because of the relative economic poverty
of Scotland as compared to England.
Scotland's industries would be protected.
Substantial compensation would be paid
to those Scots who had lost heavily
through their investment in the Darien
adventure of the 60 nineties and so on.
The 1st of May 1,707 Scotland's parliament
dissolve itself not to meet again
until the year 1999 when it was reinstated
as part of the current constitutional
reconfiguration of the United Kingdom.
So the union had taken place.
Was it one might ask
a union of absorption,
a union in which Scotland was
to be dominated by England,
a union of absorption,
or was it to be a union of fusion,
one of cooperation rather than domination?
Many Scots at the time feared
that it would be the former
in the long run.
I think it turned out to
be more of the latter.
Scott's certainly proved to have a quite
disproportionately large role almost
from the beginning of the union in
the running of the British empire,
for example,
but in the early 18th century,
it was not yet quite either.
England was not actually much interested
in dominating Scotland beyond the
question of security and indeed Scottish
affairs remained largely in the hands
of Scott's themselves.
Conversely,
it took a while before Scotland was
able to fully exploit the economic
advantages of union.
Though by the 1750s they were
indeed doing so very successfully.
The emergence of Glasgow is one of
the major Atlantic ports is one of the
biggest success stories
of that part of the union.
The union.
Then you one could say confirm neither
the fears nor initially the full hopes of
the Scots who had agreed to it,
but from the English point of view,
it had resolved a pressing
security problem and it
completed the refashioning of
the state,
which had been introduced by the
revolution of 1688 culturally,
there was an England and Scotland
and Wales as there still is,
but pipe politically.
By 1714 there was what Jonathan Swift
described as that crazy
double bottomed realm,
Great Britain
and crazy.
It was in many ways a monarchy which
was actually run by a parliament,
truly a monarchical republic in which
the king after 1,701 actually had fewer
powers.
Then we'll later granted two
presidents of the United States,
a confessional state,
and yet a confessional state which
actually had to established religions.
The Church of England in England,
the Presbyterian Church of Scotland in
Scotland and which by 1714 was headed by
a king who was actually a German Lutheran,
but was an Anglican when he was in
England and a Presbyterian when he was in
Scotland,
and meanwhile practicing
greater religious freedom.
Dan was tolerated by any other state,
saves the Netherlands,
an offshore island,
deeply hostile to foreign involvement,
deeply hostile to militarism,
and yet,
which was playing a key role in
destroying the threat of Louis,
the 14th monarchy,
and which had emerged as
a great military power.
It was all very confusing,
but there it was.
They had finally muddled through
to something that worked.